and he'll run the pick and roll pull up
20-footer
short loose ball and the rebound goes to
nick richards hook knight in transition
down the lane on the kick lamelo
angelo
excuse me
great drop by book knight gets down the
lane creates a problem there's l'angelo
shooting the ball
young man's growing right in front of
our eyes ball hard down the lane high
off the glass
great take by ball the fan favorite
l'angelo ball the people's champ they
love him out here in vegas he's got five
58-51
barnes now goes deep in the post after
hitting the three turn around jade now
just short kai jones the other way
riller cross court ball rising fire why
not
they're going crazy for league ball the
fan favorite
angelo ball the people's champ they love
him out here in vegas he's got five
58-51
barnes now goes deep in the post after
hitting the three turn around jade no
just short kai jones the other way
riller cross court ball rising fire why
not you're going crazy for liangelo here
in vegas it's his town gus
50 61 51 rather meanwhile oh my goodness
precious little too strong on the
baseline that wasn't precious
inside richard and one
they've seen his journey they obviously
know his brothers and they want to see
him make it as well
i love how the fans here are just
supporting l'angelo like crazy they are
buying into the ball family all the way
largest lead of the game right now